in der nähe der stadt grafing bei
münchen bekommen die bürger endlich eine
neue kreisstraße 1,5 millionen euro
teuer viele jahre geplant doch seit
dieser woche baustopp denn
überraschender weise steht mitten auf
der geplanten trasse eine 300 jahre alte
eiche baum oder straße das ist hier die
frage
jahrelang hatten die straßenplaner den
schützenswerten baum anscheinend
übersehen wenn ich in waldstraße rainbow
man muss auf alle fälle schauen ist
irgendwas schützenswertes drin und wenn
s und beim sie dann ist das eigentlich
erst mal total stoppen indem verstehen
sagte müssen nicht vor ort gewesen sei
bei der planung
wir haben gedacht wie kann das sein dass
man sowas nicht sieht hier fand denn man
kann es nicht erwarten
vor einigen wochen bekommt klaus
grünebach vom bund naturschutz mit dass
die altehrwürdige eiche weg soll die
trasse soll genau da entlang führen wo
der baum seit über 300 jahren steht zu
einer eilig organisierten protest
veranstaltung kommen viele grafinger sie
kämpfen für den erhalt des baumes mit
erfolg seit dieser woche sind die
baumaßnahmen unterbrochen die bagger
stehen still
aber wie kann es sein dass keine behörde
den mächtigen baum bemerkt hat die eiche
nicht in den unterlagen auftaucht ein
erklärungsversuch des zuständigen
landrat für den behörden fehler dass
dieser nicht aufgefallen ist es scheint
im nachhinein nicht nachvollziehbar zu
sein
aber da haben viele nicht konkret
hingeschaut das kann man jetzt auch
nicht nur den planer sozusagen oder der
planende behörde unterstellen sondern an
der stelle kommen viele vorbei die hier
wohnen die hier unterwegs sind sie hier
verantwortlich sind irgendwie also ganz
blöd gelaufen jetzt wird um geplant die
trasse sollen nun nicht mehr durch den
baum hindurch sondern in zehn meter
abstand an der alten eiche vorbeiführen
gut 200.000 euro wird das mindestens
mehrkosten die bürger ärgern sich über
die fehlplanung in die kosten haben wir
eigentlich diese herren zu verantworten
die eigentlich geht es vorher schon
gewusst haben und nicht darauf reagiert
haben
es ist einfach traurig waren immer sowie
einer fehlentscheidung getroffen die
dann der kleine mann aus baden muss
immerhin der mächtige baum wird jetzt
offiziell zum naturdenkmal ernannt wenn
die behörden keinen weiteren fehler
machen dann hat ja noch gut 600 jahre
lebenserwartung vor sich